To celebrate Christmas,
we tried to book Santa,
but he's at Book Soup
doing a signing
for his new coffee table book
of tasteful elf nudes.
-Luckily...
-(laughter)
we were able to get
his Austrian counterpart.
He appears at homes and hovels
all over Europe,
and his biopic Krampus
has 65% on Rotten Tomatoes.
All the way from the Teutonic
forests of Middle Europe,
Krampus is here, everybody!
-(cheering)
-(Krampus growling)
(growls, chuckles)
(growling)
(growls)
Hey, Chris,
your audience probably
doesn't recognize me,
because Americans aren't aware
of anybody's traditions
but their own.
(growls)
Yeah, I... What an authentic
Austrian accent you have.
-Uh, so...
-(laughter)
-why are you here, Krampus?
-It's 2016 now, Chris.
Better accent? Almost 2017.
Santa Claus is on the way out.
Too old, too jolly--
it makes you wonder...
what is he hiding?
He's crooked!
Crooked Santa.
All right, so you're saying
that Santa Claus is corrupt.
Yes. He's too nice.
He rewards children
for being "good"!
And that's not what
real Americans just voted for.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Oh.
They voted for kids
to be punished!
Punished with bundles of sticks.
(laughter)
That's where I come in.
Every year I go around
to people's homes
and thrash kids with sticks.
That's my thing.
-(cheering)
-MAN: Yeah.
It's what I do.
Isn't that what Christmas
is all about, Chris?
The thrashing children
with bundles of sticks?
Well, I don't... I don't know.
Comedians,
that is a good question.
What is Christmas
all about? Milana.
The thrashing of children
with bundles of sticks.
Okay, all right.
Uh, points for that.
Uh, con... that confirmation.
Nick, what is Christmas about?
Uh, Christmas is about
my Uncle Rod
taking too many close-up
creepy pictures of my wife.
All right. Uh, points.
I mean, no... no offense,
Krampus, I'm not being judgey,
but you seem to be particularly
obsessed with this idea
of thrashing children
with bundles of sticks. Why?
Uh, it's just so practical.
Think of the money
you'll save on toys.
You buy a Hatchable, right?
60, 70 bucks-- whatever
they cost, I don't know.
I don't go to toy stores.
I'm a grown man.
I send my assistant Michelle
to the toy store for me.
HARDWICK:
Okay.
Then you give the toy to the
kid, and they start screaming
because of your horns
and sulfur breath.
Wouldn't it just be cheaper
to buy one bundle of twigs
that you can use to thrash them?
Well, I mean,
I guess... I guess,
if you lay it out that way,
then-then yeah.
-Thank you.
-All right.
I mean, it seems like
you're spending a lot of time
collecting small sticks
when you could really
just grab one big stick.
That is a good point.
100 points for that.
KRAMPUS:
You know, you got a point.
Hey, come on, Krampus,
you cannot... First of all,
you're so obsessed with sticks.
-You cannot go around
hitting children wi... -Wrong.
-...with sticks and...
-Wrong.
-No, you can't. -Wrong.
No, I'm right.
You can't just go around
swatting kids with sticks.
I mean...
Hi, Billy.
Hi, Billy. Whack!
-What did Billy do? -Oh, hey,
Darren, what's up? Whack!
Why are you hitting these fake
invisible kids in front of you?
There has to be a better way.
Comedians, what's a better,
modern punishment for a child?
Aparna.
Giving them gluten.
All right, points.
Milana?
You, uh, you take away
their Pokémon
and then you tell them that
the divorce is their fault.
Okay, good, yeah.
Listen, that's what
my parents did,
and I turned out fine. Uh...
So, what is your point
with all this, Krampus?
Uh, my point is
Santa Claus is a cuck.
-What?
-Wha... -What?
You heard me.
Google it.
America needs
to upgrade this year
to a new Christmas guy:
me, Krampus,
the alt-Santa.
I... I...
I'm going to make... I'm going
to make Christmas great again.
I can tell you that.
I'm going to make Christmas
great again.
All right.
So, comedians...
rather than, uh,
beating people with wood,
there's got to be a better way
to make Christmas great again.
Uh, so how do we do that?
Aparna.
Putting... putting
the Christ back in
"Jesus Christ,
this country is (bleep)!"
All right, points.
Points.
I was going to say thrash
your children with bundles!
But whatever.
If you were wan...
really want to... their children
thrashed with sticks
on Christmas?
Uh... (scoffs)
Not a children, Chris.
Just most children.
(cackles)
My elves will start a database
to keep track
of all the naughty kids
and to make sure
they're all rounded up
and sent to camps...
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey,
hey! -Hey, no.
-No, you whoa, you hey.
-No, you!
-Let me finish.
-Okay.
Send them to summer camps.
Oh, okay, all right, that's...
There we go.
Where they will be sorted
according to religion
and sexual orientation.
-All right, that's it,
we're done. -What?
We're done with you, please.
Thank you, Krampus.
-Not thank you.
-You! You!
Don't hit anyone on the way out.